Taylor Swift versus her former record
label the battle is on why you gotta be
so big machine records fired back at the
singer on Friday issuing a lengthy and
we mean lengthy statement to ET after
she accused the labels execs Scooter
Braun and Scott Borchetta of preventing
her from performing her old songs at the
2019
American Music Awards saying in part
quote Taylor the narrative you have
created does not exist I would very much
like to be excluded from this narrative
oh damn let's rewind on Thursday Taylor
released this statement on Instagram
alleging that scooter and Scott put the
kibosh on her AMA performance plans
writing quote I'm not allowed to perform
my old songs on television because they
claim that would be rear according my
music before I'm allowed to next year
Taylor also said she had plans to
release a new Netflix documentary about
her life over the past few years but
that both scooter and Scott have
declined the use of her older music and
performance footage for the project do
not let anything stop you from making
art but here's where things get really
interesting Taylor claims Scott would
let her use the footage if she agreed to
not rerecord copycat versions of her old
songs something Taylor announced she
planned to do after scooter bought into
big machine earlier this year giving him
ownership of her old masters huh it's
it's just unbelievable Taylor added
quote this is wrong neither of these men
had a hand in the writing of those songs
and she urged her fans to let scooter
and Scott know how they feel a man does
something it's strategic
a woman does the same thing it's
calculated a man is allowed to react a
woman can only overreact now big machine
is denying Taylor's claims saying they
were shocked by her post that they claim
was based on false information adding at
no point did we
Tayler could not perform on the AMAs or
block her Netflix special big machines
statement went on to accuse Taylor of
owing millions of dollars to the company
and called Taylor's post calculated
before addressing the popstar directly
quote Taylor the narrative you have
created does not exist all we ask is to
have a direct and honest conversation
when that happens you will see there is
nothing but respect kindness and support
waiting for you on the other side is it
just me or was that shade wrapped up in
a pretty bow but the drama doesn't stop
there you guys on Friday a spokeswoman
for Taylor responded to big machine
telling et in a statement that the label
is trying to deflect by making it about
money adding that quote a big machine
owes Taylor 7.9 million dollars in
unpaid royalties
anyway Taylor's fans are up in arms over
the whole thing and so is Taylor's
bestie Selena Gomez the singer weighed
in on her instace story writing in part
quote my heart is so heavy right now it
makes me sick and extremely angry you've
robbed and crushed one of our best
songwriters of our time an opportunity
to celebrate all of her music with fans
and the world she ended her lengthy post
writing I just want a change of heart
something tells me that this story isn't
even close to being over and of course
you can count on ET to bring you all the
latest so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Haley
Stephens bye for now
[Music]